okay so this is edgy gonna be two
episodes in one cuz as maybe you know
December's kind of a busy time for us uh
was it like two or three videos a day
now so we have the gravity falls be logs
is Disney summer the normal NZ stuff and
this so one thing kind of had to go by
the wayside and we've kind of decided
since its released once a week it's this
yeah so but uh so these two episodes uh
man what a lot happens if I keep
checking my phone wickets it just busy
time um by train to catch yeah but after
there's a clock right there so I can
just put this away uh so to him is a lot
happens talk comes back which I did not
see coming I really thought I was
awesome yeah and she gets into the
action and she's awesome in it um
Zelda's pretty much made this what you
got mecha made yeah run space of offices
complete kuvira's spirit weapon is now
boom-boom-boom-boom-boom
mega made so this awesome gigantic
monstrosity uh powered by her that is
just like the icing on the cake I'm now
convinced this is my favorite Korra
villain because like just seeing her in
general Pacific Rim she's like she's
like one of those Jaeger pilots
yeah but she's also like got the Zen
master that she's a Jagermeister there
we go
a Jager master Jager like yeah um so
she's now gonna take for public City
with the super awesome weapon that's on
you know the mecha made much to the
dismay of general Iroh who has a line
yes but just still nice to even hear the
name honestly it's it's nice to see IRA
again but I was in there might give him
more lines it's the boss man um
you respect the boss so uh so Toph and
and they've uh they go in and they're
gonna save their family and they do
exactly that
all while Lin uh comes to grips with her
mother and it's funny even though it's
only like just a few sentences I felt so
much more awkwardness and
uncomfortableness in that talk when they
were eating that I have like
between the two sisters I was like wow
like that was kind of a heavy scene and
results yes this was another thing there
I feel like losing that one episode to a
clip show was not helpful because I'm
like you could have drawn that out a
little more like well we had a little
sister before yeah I just feel like I
missed something somewhere like I I get
it wasn't easy and the issues with you
know their father and stuff but it I
don't know I like it was it was talked
about a bit and then all of a sudden got
this big like dump of emotion and
feelings I'm like I just feel like you
didn't bleed into it somehow like it's
kind of like we need to resolve this now
just do it like you know I agree but it
I felt like it still worked because the
writing was just so tight and so precise
but still had the emotional I family
well on me actually
I would've liked more I definitely want
like more but it's like I thought still
work I thought was still affected I
think it works well enough yeah so so
they go and get them back uh and the
giant mecha maid is there it's about to
blow up Republic City they agreed to
surrender
I love the sound that thing makes you
there oh yes rent it so that dubstep Wow
flowers yes I feel like I'm watching a
Michael Bay trailer Wow yeah or it's
area crisper don't like it's a cool
sound that's why he's using all these
trailers uh and so they they agree to
surrender but Cora has her own plan she
goes and kidnaps Zelda's future husband
or so we thought link no yeah so grabs
him it finds out that like he's totally
separate from his family now wants
nothing to do with it so Cora tries to
stand as new family's fiance and say you
will never see her again you know we
will take you and we will really 'never
I was looking at because I'm like he's
right I that one I saw coming like well
she's not really gonna hurt him so how
is this gonna work but I did think I'm
like the one thought I had initially was
that just they were gonna say hey we
have him so if you ever want to see him
again like I'm never giving him back and
of course goofy recalled that by just
saying you know I could probably do okay
without him yeah well I like know that
was like oh no no you know what I like
about that you definitely had this idea
that like she's like oh what a sacrifice
but you know what
great leaders have to make sacrifices
you know it was very it was very like
this upsets me but you know what I got
to do what I got to do so how much eggs
boom break him yeah I just I kind of
didn't see that one coming I'm like I
mean like I did for that because now you
know he's gonna ice tears yeah well I
ice I saw it gonna like when she starts
readying the way like I saw it there and
I can I guess I did see something coming
because they MoMA where she's like and
then we'll get married and everything
will be great when she hugs him that
smile on her face was very weird just
like no I think she was like happy with
him and stuff initially but again it's
based on going on it yeah ed like it you
know now it's it's the Empire it's that
we will do all of it and stuff and you
know it's like no no I've come way too
far to be stopped by this it's a shame
that this is gonna be horse course plan
was brilliant like when she's like fine
but if I'm running I'm taking you with
me you're never gonna say I'm like
brilliant in like the all the characters
in this round with the exception of
well Marco wasn't impressing me and
neither was the prince of a prince even
the prince had some good moments though
he had he had a moment but it was still
with like I know they want to make him
goofy and stuff like he's kind of the
new Bolin but like I couldn't even go to
the bathroom I'm like inspiring speech
like okay III saw kind of working
because like everyone can know is he's
pathetic but like he's also confident in
this talk and it's like I thought it was
one of the for me was one of the comedic
moments ed just it didn't work for me
I'm like yeah I thought it I rely really
don't know if you thought that was bold
and funny and a good moment for him and
then makos still getting the shaft is
one moment to do something and it's just
like you're creating more problems
people are asking too many questions no
no the one moment for me like the
comedian I'm just like really was like
you know we have to keep the little boy
behind why because your farts are simply
too loud it's like point taken I'm like
okay no and I just wanted to the other I
just want to be in the recording booth
when she read that line because I'll bet
you a thousand bucks she couldn't read
that with a straight time well and milk
is like the other parts of I'm okay with
cuz it's like it's a little kid kids but
if you could do that as a little kid you
what he'll live adults would even do it
but it was a bomb - yeah that was my mom
uh uh yeah um but ya know that I thought
really yeah but one line I did love is
when they find out that mecha maids
coming a week early and then they're
flying on the bubbler he's like oh my
god they've got this giant mocha it's
like bolin like did you know but oh yeah
sure of course I knew about this oh of
course
like that's why I agree that's why I
provide up to you yeah that is not to
bring that that's why I chose not to
bring it up of course I did know uh so
yeah it ends with this big explosion
happening and build up I like reminds me
of like that I I do I will say this what
everybody was all in like all the little
ducks in a row and all the honors and
stuff no not even two towers I'm just
like I swear I'm gonna see 80 80
Walker's just coming around the corner
of that mountain like you have it
dad had this animal because they're
supposed to be evacuating it had this
very Empire Strikes Back thing like this
is not going to end well that this
season really does just get better and
better and I am so happy that it's kind
of I mean we haven't gotten to the idea
at the end goods grow double you'll know
but I'm so happy that's just kind of
like for a final season this is such a
good final season it just gets bigger
and bigger it's more and more build-up
and its butts kind of delivering too
because the action is so good and you
see this giant killer robot and
everything so I'm just happy to be
watching Korra and there's just not much
for me to really pick apart like yeah
it's like really really solid
it's very tight like I love when they
were whatever getting the family out
then you cut Tokoro who's meditating
going to the spirit world I'm like yeah
none of these feel like time wasters
everything seems a shame that it took so
long for them to get their groove I'm
not blaming them entirely we all know
about the issues with Nick but it sucks
that we had to get three seasons to
where they're finally just like we've
nailed it we got this where as you know
avatar the original you could argue
season one's a little but it it hits
that point pretty clear anyways yeah
this was all over the map but now I mean
it was worth it for this season yeah
it's such a good season my fingers
across that cuz we still got how many
episodes are left I don't know I have no
idea but but we're obviously in the
final you know chapter here so yes so
I'm excited to see where it's gonna go
um we'll try our best to keep getting
these out weekly like it says just
December is not sorry about this one we
can blame Nick for they could have ran
this like after the New Year's there you
know yeah that's running now we're I
guess so Coco and we will see you next
episode take care